every time they hear the helicopter here
there's a sudden burst of Hope and a
rush of adrenaline
eight days after an apocalyptic
earthquake the staff at Adana City
Hospital are still receiving survivors
this time it's a 26 year old teacher
this is astonishing to see more than a
week
has managed to pull through what
strength that must have taken and what
horror she must have endured
[Music]
this is the moment M A at goal was
discovered
it's more than 200 hours since her
six-story building has collapsed
she's exhausted on the edge of life and
death
in the eight days she's been trapped she
might be suffering tissue damage due to
hunger and thirst our patients will most
likely suffer from renal failure and
that's why we'll have to monitor her in
our Intensive Care Unit
[Music]
it's hard to Fathom how anyone made it
through these doors especially
eight-month-old beer Jay she fell from
the fifth floor
her leg is broken but doctors are
hopeful she'll make a full recovery
a mother neeli thought she'd lost all
three of her children
at first when I called out to my kids I
didn't hear any response I didn't want
to get out alive then I thought how will
I survive this if my family are no more
amazingly BJ and her eldest sister did
make it but in the rubble neelai found
the body of her other child
all of my daughters are Miracles but I
am without one I have lost her now I'm
seeking refuge in my daughter birje
being alive I find solace in her
in Antarctica the burden of the search
is heavy
mounds of Despair everywhere
but no one is ready to let go the night
before a couple was rescued and now the
race is on to find their 26 year old son
you don't hear sounds anymore after
three four days you cannot see the
sounds but you say
if you hear my voice can you please hit
against the wall with something any kind
of nuts and we have some gadgets on our
gadgets we can hear clearly
even if it's scratching the wall with
the nails
but after an agonizing weight
the worst news the family forced to
identify his body
[Music]
is as cruel as it is coarse
yet still they search looking for any
little clue that may help them Salvage
life or at very least honor the dead
Cordelia Lynch Sky News and Takia turkey